こんにちはん版のみ社長で最近ね自民に増えても御霊い動画の方なんです
俺こんな技真島まず衆妙
終わりだね毎日マジでコンビニ弁当を食べてたまに外食英語で自分で実践することが
ないんですよこれはねもう人間としてねは今ですがコンビニ民党とが在職すんなって
言ってるわけじゃないんですけど毎回作業してると本当に彼に悪いと思ってて自炊が
できないやめれないんでホンダで少しずつでもいいから実践チックなコトハ
れていた場合って僕を持ってるわけなんですよそんでブレーキ小瓶と会社でクルー
続けること言ってコピーカーで来たのかってやっぱりね多いんですよ
添加物とか館力でものがこんなにこのモードは多分ないできないけどちょっと非常に
危険な状態に陥ってるのでとりあえず簡単なものからでいい
簡単なのはでいいからこれは料理を始めなきゃいけないという状況に陥ってるんで早速
で共演料理の方やけど ok
を作る料理がコツだミルクセーキでございますみなさんミルクセーキぷしてますか
誰かで知ってる人も知らない人もいると思うんですけどもあれはね俺が差し日町学校の
月かなあその頃の初めは体が弱く
簡単なスポーツクラブに通っていました無理やり運動させられていたので汗は止まらず
汗をたくさんかきました初めは喉がカラカラになっていつもそのタイプ巻の十数デー
飲んでました数えはある日魅力市域というものを見つけました
なんだこれは何だああはじめ迷った挙句
魅力生地を買って飲んだところ旨い馬次だ
そういう感じですね小学校の時初めてミルクセーキてはそんなんですけども美味しい
ですよ
ミルクセーキどこでものれって言うもんじゃないんでちょっと自分で作り方を覚えて
以前の魅力選挙のビデオに今日はなりたいと思います今日まずちゃんとした料理動画だ
から舌クックパッドの位置論人気捏造していくぜ10社って用意するもの牛乳200 c
花ビルの
持ってないよ
ちょっとほかなんでしょうこれ4ゲテモノ卵を1個牛乳200種資産と大さじ一杯
バニラエッセンス少々
順調と佐藤が釣れちゃったからハチミツで多分大丈夫だと思いますハチミツでし
ましょう
こっちはおいしいかもしれないから始めスペシャルではもう一つ作り方1まず材料を
全て混ぜます
来なくタブシェイキングするんで
ペットボトルとかまず得るものが良いと思います多分まず材料を全て混ぜますこっから
ではマジでやってたまご黄身だけを取らなきゃいけない
だったパパって問われだ10までなんでもらえたし待てでもいいぞ
このます白いとこだけ
なんではれたそれはだから2牛豚だけなのに黄色いとこだけ回収しなきゃいけない
でしょ
余裕っしょ a うんじゃあ黄色いところでたんだよ
いい君だけ k 君だけ入れます
ねはいってやっぱちょっとメット案内版いなかったんちょっともう一回
次はちゃんとしとけ
頼むぞゆっくり入れたお前ら全員機入るとの対比のベルト池杯入れてねー
パッ1パック ok これバカなのかな
君が入りました牛乳を200獅子入れます
粉を頭たぶんこんなもんだと思いますマッチはちみつ大さじ1杯大さじ
いっぱいおっ今日パネライフェンスを少量入れます
医学寝てないようなハサミでカッティングしなきゃいけないんですかこれ花と葉できる
フラワーにご
頭を出てきてるぞ今苦かったが出てきてるよ秋だしてるとピタちょっとでからね
恥じらい清楚ホットまずいからねもう一回やってるか
凄まじいなこれはペットボトルで歌をしてよく振って完成です
何度今冬ん
よし阿部ねー
入るで完成しました
んはぁっ
なぜただけだ混ぜただけなんですけどもやっぱりコインちょっとものを買ってつけ
るっていう事がまず料理第一歩なんで今日も大きいに辛抱ですよ
わかんないんだけどみんな知ってることを横アンディスプレイず俺が生きてきた中で
どんな中ではこれが一番美味しかった
飲んでみませていただきます
me
バーン
b 2
バッハ
ています